what is it what is the job of writing
like I mean we had to Ian Edwards on
here and he's been in the writers rooms
for like decades but like what is your
experience been like in the writers room
my experience in the writers room has
been incredible but I do have to preface
it by saying that every writers room is
very different the way every show
operates is different so like not just
the experience of who you work with but
how that room operates it really depends
on who's running the room and who you're
writing for and with so like our day is
typically 9:30 10:00 a.m. to 6 7 o'clock
ok so not crazy hours like I've heard of
some writers rooms that go till 11:00
p.m. 2:00 a.m. on some nights doing
rewrites and stuff our writers room is
pretty respectful of our lives outside
of it like I still almost every night
have time to go and do sets after the
show or after after the day of work but
it really it boils down to like the way
we operate is we typically spend like
the first two months of and we have a
very long rise room we have like an
eighth month
room which is way long that's above
average yeah yeah I mean again it varies
but from my understanding most shows go
for maybe 20 weeks and and we're close
to 35 or 40 but we spend the first few
months all in the room together all day
planning out the season planning out the
story arcs for the episodes and the
characters and then once we go into
breaking down individual episodes that's
when we spend less time collectively and
kind of go off into our own offices to
work on whatever we specialize in for
that episode so it's like a very
collaborative effort from the start
again that then gets broken down into
different people doing their specialties
that's what's beautiful about missus
Mazal is like my wife and I got
instantly hooked and a big part of that
is the writing and when I had Beth
Stelling on here she talked about on
crashing they would almost just have
tent poles of like okay we want Pete and
his ex-wife's boyfriend to end up in bed
together how that happens we don't know
but we like they would just set these
little like finish lines or checkpoints
to hit is that kind of how No
ours is the opposite I so I write with
Amy sherman-palladino and Dan Palladino
who are the creators of the show or also
the head writers and they are meticulous
with their writing and one thing that's
different about our show for most other
shows is from what I understand most
other shows the writers have to be there
at the taping and at the filming so if a
line doesn't work
writers are there to pitch alts on our
show the actors and actresses have to be
WordPerfect so like once the script is
finalized that's what they're saying
there's no like there's no this joke
isn't working can we get in halt it's
like no this is the joke save the joke
like our actors and actions don't miss
of of a but they are literally
word-for-word WordPerfect on our script
so there's no like there's dozens of
rewrites before the script is finalized
amongst ourselves but once that script
is out that's the script mm-hmm how do
you when you talked about you first kind
of beat out the season and then you go
into individual episodes is it just
looking at where we're starting in this
season where we want to end up and then
kind of reverse engineering it like how
do you build a story yeah I mean it
really comes down to what are we trying
to get accomplished for the show and for
each character you know that a big
lesson in writing in general is just
having a vision and like if you know
where you're planning on going it makes
everything else fall in line much easier
so obviously midge is the main character
in the show so her story is the most
important but there's so many different
pieces to her world that you kind of map
out every characters journey and that's
not to say it's so rigid that like in
week one we're like this is what happens
all season for every character things
change within the realm of the season
like what we plan on happening episode 5
when we are writing episode 1 might
change based on how we kind of
reconfigure things as we're going along
but in general you try to map out each
character's journey individually and
then what it means in the universe of
the show so that it can all kind of come
together and work off of each other and
how in terms of writing the show how
much is it bouncing ideas off verbally
verse actually like sitting down and
putting on the page there's a lot of
again we like because our show writers
and our showrunner is the pallid
they're like legendary TV writers so for
people that don't know they met years
ago as writers on the original Roseanne
they've gone on they created the Gilmore
Girls dan was the showrunner for Family
Guy for a while so like these are these
are like classic TV writers who it's not
like a show where it's their first harad
and they're kind of feeling that like
they know exactly what they want they
know what they're doing and Amy is very
much a boss so it's like it's not one of
those writers rooms where everyone comes
in equally pitching's like we all shut
the up and listen to what Amy says
and then we listen to what Dan says and
then when they need us we feel it that
I've given this example one time before
I feel like our writers room operates a
lot like the Chicago Bulls during the
Jordan year so it's like you had Michael
Jordan you have Scottie Pippen that's
Amy and Dan I just have to be Steve Kerr
you know like when they pass me the ball
I need to hit the open jumper and we'll
win a championship I don't need to be
Michael Jordan I don't need to be
Scottie Pippen I just need to do my job
when they give me the opportunity to do
my job
so so I'm not in there trying to pitch a
million jokes a day it's just like I
listen to what they want and then when I
have ideas that are worth sharing I do
it and that a big lesson for the writers
room that I would say to aspiring
writers a lot of it is you're gonna be
spending eight ten twelve hours a day
with these people you need to learn how
to get along like personalities have to
mesh for a show to do well so as
valuable as it is to have good things to
say it's also very valuable to know when
to shut the up you know like
writers rooms are annoying if there's
eight people in there constantly trying
to one-up each other and get the
funniest joke and sometimes the biggest
thing you can do to advance your
position in the room is learning how to
listen especially if you're listening to
people who are smarter than you and
better at you than what you're trying to
do do you have any other tips for
writers that's gold man no I mean you
know there's like all the cliches of
writing which are cliches for a reason
they're true like write what you know
draw on real experience show don't tell
little things like that all matter but
honestly a nugget of wisdom I would say
is like if you're ever fortunate enough
to be working with great writers and
people who have been doing what
you hope to do pay attention like take
advantage of the situation don't be on
your phone you know check in Twitter and
Instagram when like you might be missing
nuggets of wisdom that will further your
career from legendary people around you
and that's got to be gratifying that you
booked this writing gig they saw your
standup yeah and we're like we've got to
hire this guy well it was gratifying on
on several levels so first of all the
show is about a woman who ends up like
kind of back handedly falling into the
world of stand-up so they wanted
stand-up comedians in the room and so
season one I went in pretty much as a
consultant for the stand-up but I made
myself invaluable in the room because
it's also about a Jewish family and even
though Amy sherman-palladino his father
was Jewish he's not very religious
doesn't know a lot about it but the
family were writing about her like
pretty observant Jews and even though I
was brought in to help with the stand-up
where I was the biggest asset ended up
kind of helping with the Jewish religion
stuff and that's that's one of those
things where I grew up in a very
religious home and I was always proud of
being Jewish but as you can imagine any
kid being brought up with a lot of
religion like I was also kind of
resentful of having so much religion
forced upon me or like different things
that I couldn't do because I had to
observe the religion and then two three
decades later so much of my upbringing
became the exact reason why I succeed in
certain field so it's like so cool you
never know when life experience that you
didn't necessarily appreciate growing up
will come into play and so it's like I
got this job and I'm thriving in this
job on a very successful show partly
because of Sam but also partly because
of the religious foundation my parents
gave me that I didn't even really
appreciate at the time mmm your mother
chose another another piece of advice I
would give to writers is just like draw
on your life experience you never know
exactly where that experience is going
to take you but like be grateful for
whatever upbringing experience you have
because that is what adds to the voice
that you can then contribute to a
project
so maybe advice for comics which is a
lot of this show a comic that's wanting
to get into a writers room
what advice do you have for how they can
actually get a seat at the table I mean
honestly it's it's luck meeting
preparation you know like you can have
writing is incredibly competitive so
many people want to do it and there's
only a few spots so so luck definitely
plays a part into it but when you're
lucky enough to have the opportunity you
have to be prepared for that opportunity
which means having your spec scripts
having your pilot scripts having
something to say you know so it's like
you have to do the work when no one's
looking to be ready when people are
looking is what I would say boom is mic
drop and when you say would you say you
said have your spec scripts have your
pilot yeah the tangibles they need ya
and you don't and you don't know what
necessarily they're gonna ask for for
those that don't a spec script is when
you write a script of a show that exists
so like if you were to write your
version of Modern Family or whatever you
know like you write a 30 minute sitcom
that people already know and what that
does is it proves that you can write
four characters that already exists it
shows that you can mold your voice to a
voice of a show and fit in cuz like if
you get hired to write on season four of
a show that's already been running those
characters already speak a certain way
that world already obviously operates in
a certain way so that's proven that your
mind can mold to the universe that's
already built in then a pilot script is
your own original idea and that shows
where your voice actually stands out and
so those are two key components of
having samples but again I got a very
high end writing job that's literally
changed my life and didn't even submit a
writing packet that came off of my
standup and then more importantly like
stand-up is what got me in the room with
the Paladino x' but it was my interview
that got me the job and that spoke more
to what I was talking about earlier just
like personalities meshing we just
talked for two hours and they could tell
I was a person they could tolerate being
around everyday in the room mm-hmm
makes sense but how you write for
yourself and stand up and how you write
for these voices multiple actors on
screen like yes there how do you how do
you start it put it through
different filters like that well it's
been crazy because it's not just writing
for myself versus multiple characters
but I'm writing for multiple characters
who are doing stand-up in the 60s
so it's also like a very different style
it's like so what was the question how
do I do that it's like you almost have
to if okay I'm writing for my own
personal stand-up I put it through this
filter I'm writing for a mid right now I
put it through this filter like you
almost have to have all these different
voices going on your head in a sense
right yeah I mean that's that's what
part of the skill comes into play like
really good writers can write for other
people and I think for stand-ups who are
looking to get into writing one skill
that may extend stand-ups a great
standup is being able to open your eyes
to other experiences and being able to
be empathetic or aware of other
viewpoints so that you can then connect
from your own viewpoint to there so it's
really a matter of stepping outside
yourself a little bit and there's a lot
of trial and error like I submit a lot
of jokes and a lot of storylines that
don't get accepted for the show and then
a few do you know it's like you got to
take your shots and just hope that
you're putting quality into any of the
work that you put forward and you
submitted a lot of to a lot of other
shows before actually booking them yeah
and that's what was so interesting is I
submitted probably know like 20 to 30
writing packets over the years to other
shows that I always got to the second
round or the final round and then
ultimately didn't went out didn't get
the job but that's kind of what I was
talking about of like doing the work
while no one is looking to be prepared
it's like if you really want to be a
writer then you have to be willing to
spend hours and days and weeks and
months doing packets for free that might
get you in the room in hopes of one day
hitting you know it's like you can't be
lazy with this if you really want
it then you got to be willing to do it
and and what that means is doing it for
free until someone is willing to pay you
and when it comes to a spec script let's
say you're submitting to Modern Family
do you want to send a spec script about
Modern Family or at least the tangent oh
yes you know you do I mean again it's
like the rules have changed so much and
they're constantly dynamic so I don't
want to be giving advice that is right
for one person wrong for the other
there's no like concrete rules but from
what I've heard you don't want to send a
screen
of the show you're trying to write for
to that show partly because from a
liability standpoint if they were to end
up doing an episode down the road that
was similar to your idea they don't want
any kind of confusion or lawsuit of like
feeling like they stole your idea so you
want to send a spec script of another
show that everyone has seen because you
know it has to be a popular show so they
most likely know the characters in the
show you're writing for but it shouldn't
be the show you're trying to write for
because that's where there's like a
conflict of interest with ideas
[Music]
I breath